هذا السؤال مساعد يعني يمكن شوي يضيق صدرك
معي صدرك واسع انت لكن هذا يقول همم
الاستاذ الدكتور ابراهيم المعجل من
الطموحين العمليين لكن يعيبه التحيز لفئه
معينه موظفي الصندوق وعدم العداله في
توزيع المكافات وامتيازات
والتعدي والظلم عن الموظفين الصندوق
القدامى اللي ينظف فترات كبيره في الصندوق
ولاهم عالي لكنهم الان يعيشون حتى تطفيش
وتطنيش
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه وانا اعمل جريس
يستضيف قاعده التحول وقاده الاعمال وقاده
الراي مع المستجدات المستهدفات رؤيه
السعوديه 20 30 ضيف حلقه اليوم ما هو غريب
عليكم اسمك كان موجود في الحلقه الثانيه
من حلقات بودكاست سراب اللي هو الدكتور
ابراهيم المعجل رئيس التنفيذي لصندوق
التنميه الصناعيه يمكن يحفزني اني ارجع
ادعوا الدكتور مره ثانيه لهالحلقه حاجتين
الحاجه الاولى الحلقه الاولى كانت قديمه
في فتره ثلاث سنوات
تقريبا
مستجدات اللي صارت فيها الفتره والسنه
الثانيه وهذا هو اخر لقاء الدكتور في همم
فتره عمله همم
قادر الى تجربه جديده فكانت نهايه الحلقه
الحديث كده بسيط عن همم المرحله الجايه
ومفهوم الاثر همم اللي يؤمن فيه الدكتور
ابراهيم همم اما الحلقه فكانت مثلته في
البدايه ذكرنا شويه
فوق الصناعه ليش احنا مهتمين بالصناعه
اشتورها في التحول الاقتصادي لعيشه في
السعوديه تكلمني على المشهد الصناعي بشكل
عام همم سنوات الماضيه وبعدين دخلنا بعمق
في الصندوق تكلمني على التحول اللي صار في
الصندوق في على مستوى علاقته بالقطاع
الخاص ومنتجات على مستوى المنشاه نفسها
همم والفريق اللي فيها وعلى مستوى علاقتها
بالمنظومه والقطاعات وبعدين دخلنا على
متابعه بعض الارقام اللي حكوا عنها في
الحلقه السابقه في موضوع نسبه قروض
المتوسطه في موضوع اشتراطات همم الضمانات
اللحيه تصير مبالغ فيها وتثقل كاهل
المستفيدين من الصندوق على موضوع التحول
لتقنيه الجيل الرابع على الموضوع همم في
النهايه شويه موضوع التجمع الصناعي واقراض
الشركات همم السيارات الكهربائيه مثل لوسي
دوسير وكيف ممكن هذا الشيء همم يعني يرتبط
باستراتيجيه الصناعه وكيف يمكن هذا الشيء
يفرق معنا همم كان نقطه تحليه بحسب في
الحلقه وفي الاخير ختمنا كالعاده بمجموعه
من سيادتكم الثمينه مثل
اعتراض احد الموظفين على الاهتمام
بالموظفين الجدد في الصندوق وتهميش بعض
الموظفين القدامى من وجهه نظر هذا الموظف
التركيز على تمكين المراه وزياده نسبتها
في الصندوق همم ايش الدوافع اللي مثل هذه
الخطوه الكلام على همم الفرق اللي يراها
الدكتور بين قائد السابق مع الفالح وقائد
الحالي مع الخريف همم في منظومه الصناعه
وغيرها من الثمينه اترككم مع الحوار حياك
الله مساعد شرفتنا ونورتنا الله يحفظك
سعيد وجودي معكم هنا مره ثانيه كان امس
وانا في لقاء ثاني واسمع الحين ما شاء
الله فوق ال100 لقاء وفوق العصر ملايين
مشاهده واستماع وكده شيء صراحه
لضيوف المرحله الاولى
منصه او برنامج مغمور يعني انت انت سجلتني
على الحلقه الثانيه ومن بين خمسه ضيوف حق
الموسم الاول انت الوحيد الي ما بيني
وبينك علاقه شخصيه واقفه فمن هذه كلهم
اقنعتهم بحب خشوم يعني تكفون تعالوا انتم
الوحيد اللي ما اعرفك
وقبيله الدعوه وكنت حلقه الثانيه في
برنامج ما نشر وقته ولا حلقه وما هو معروف
تقبل الدعوه الذاكره الوقت صراحه سبب
الاول انا عموما
الشباب واللي متحمسين وكذا دائما عندنا في
اي شخص شعبه متحمس شيء ودي اني اكون لو
جوزها صغير من قصتهم شيء ثاني طبعا في
تاريخ بين الوالده الله يحفظه الوالد وعمر
همم
بس عشان الاسود
العمر اللي بينهم بس ولولاء ابوي كلمني
ولا ابوي يدري اصلا انا كان على البرنامج
ولا ظهر والدك وقت تدري صح بس انه تقدير
انت عارف الواحد
فعلا انت قاعد تتكلم عنها من زاويه يمكن
تشوفها بسيطه بس اثرها غير عادي يعني
بالذات في البدايات وانت وانت منصه مغموره
تماما سهل اليوم اني اقنع احد مو سهل بس
اسهل كثير يقنع اليوم ضيف يشارك فيه
الصفراء ما بصى بلد نفسها وصار لها
جمهورها وصار ممكن يوصل رسائل من خلالها
وفي روايه وفي عائد مقابل المخاطر حق
الظهور الاعلام اللي هي موجوده في اي ظهور
بس هذي المرحله يعني يتطلب الموضوع الدعم
عالي جدا عشان همم الواحد يعني يقدر يكسر
ضيوف مثل الشربات وهذا ال- ال- البناء
التراكم من الضيوف هو اللي فتحنا الابواب
الاخرين فيعني اهنيك عليها العاده اتمنى
تستمر عليها واتمنى الاسم باعونا برده ان
كان عندهم ان شاء الله
استقبل باذن الله لا اشجع الجميع
برامج مغموره ايضا ويساعدون شباب جداد يا
سلام باذن الله الله يقويهم على طاري
التشجيع كيف كانت مباراه الجمعه اول شيء
بارك للجميع يعني فوز المغرب صراحه فريق
عربي اول مره همم
سرحت العيال وايش معناها وتحمس وفكره انها
فريق عربي وصل الحين نصف النهائي كوره مره
بس يعني طبعا الحلقه هذه هتنشر بعد نهايه
كاس العالم كلها لعلها ان شاء الله وقت
هنشوف وين وصل المغرب بس حاليا هو الان
واصل صراحه بغض النظر يعني
صحيح صحيح
يوم الجمعه وكان جميله صراحه حماس حماسيه
بس حلو مفهوم
الختات انا سميه يعني انت عندك سفرات
كثيره بس قصيره وجيت شرحت لي علاقه
هالموضوع
بالطبيعه عملك وانشغالك وكيف انك تقدر
توازن ما بين السفرات كثيره قصيره مع
اولادك مع والديك مع اصدقائك
ومع انك يعني مسؤول عن اشياء كثيره
تركز على ايش يعني الواحد مثلا يقول ليش
اطلع يومين نحنا حتى انا وزملائي وعيالنا
طلعنا السيرلانكا ويكا طبعا الخميس
يبقى لو رحنا اسبوع ما تسوى
السؤال هي طبعا لو اسبوع افضل السؤال
الخيار اسبوع مو موجود الخيار الموجود هل
اروح اجلس يومين هنا ولا اروح اخلق ذكرى
انا وابنئي اذا هي املج ولا هي رحنا مثلا
جمعه سبت النجران وانا عقبه عندي وكذا
رحنا يوم ونصف مجموعه من الزملاء وابناءنا
هل وين تخلق ذكره التجربه اللي تبقى لك مع
زملائك ولا مع ابناءك ولا كده عليها
التعب
الحمد لله
اربع خمس ساعات افضل وطلعنا يومين رحنا
البر بس اربع خمس ساعات ذكريات جميله واذا
خيار الثاني الخيار الثاني اللي جالس
في السرير نائم ما ما صار زي اليوم
منطقه الشفرات الابو يومين
انا حياتي كلها
الان هل العشاء يطلعه هي شفره هل خلقت
ذكرى او لا من ذكريات الجميله هي حوارنا
الاول همم
ابريل 2019
[موسيقى]
صندوق التنميه الصناعي
واليوم ما زلت انت على يعني على راس
الصندوق همم وهذه حلقه ثانيه بعض الاشياء
اللي حكينا عنها
الحلقه السابعه
اللي مهتم يعرف فكره الصندوق تاريخ نشاته
هذه حطيناها انا ودي ادخل هنا على جوانب
التحول
وخلينا نبدا بالصوره الكبيره قبل ما ادخل
في الصندوق القطاع الصناعي بشكل عام من
لما رسميا كلفت بقياده الصندوق الى اليوم
نهايتها 22 اربع سنوات شهدت يمكن اهم
الاحداث اللي مرتبطه بقطاع الصناعي في
السعوديه لخص لنا التحول اللي صار في قطاع
الصناعي
اسمح لي ابدا باهميه الصناعه الصناعه مهمه
جدا للتحول الاقتصادي اذا نبي نستمر حنا
من افضل نكبر عشان اقعد ان شاء الله نكبر
15 اقتصاد مهم جدا نبني انقطاع زي قطاع
الصناعه
ملخص اهداف التحول الاقتصادي كامله
هدف الاول خلقه وظائف امنيه المعرفه الهدف
الثاني تحسين ميزان المدفوعات خاصه من
خلال قيمه مضافه عاليه هذه اهم هدفين
يتحول اقتصادي ليه مركز
الصين
الوظائف مهمه جدا
اغلى ما عندي تراهم السعوديات احنا 20
مليون سعودي سعوديه
عشان استمر لكم اكبر اقتصادات العالم لازم
القيمه من كل شخص ينتجها كل شخص يكون عالي
جدا فلازم استثمر فيهم اولا ومكنهم
يسافرون من انفسهم في التعليم وكذا
وسقط القطاعات تسمحن منمون المضافه اللي
يخلقونها عالي جدا فالاولى خلق ظاهره ذات
قيمه مضافه
الثانيه
اقتصاد لازم اللي اشتريه كثر الابيعه صح
يعني ابسط شيء ممكن فهذا الاسم
انا الان ادعمني الله انعم علي الله
سبحانه وتعالى بالبترول فقدرتنا كبلد على
شراء عاليه لان عندي منتجه هو بترول
تكلفته قليله سعره عالي فرق السعر هذا
داخل يدخل للاقتصاد ككل واقدر اشتري فيه
اللي بيننا في البلد الحمد لله بيننا
الاجهزه
منه في المملكه الساعه 6:54 في السعوديه
لافضل بعد اني بكره اقدر اسجل من المملكه
وزي ما تصدرنا نحنا صناعه البتروكيماويه
وبعض الصناعات الغذائيه صرت اصنع شيء ب
4/5 وبيعها ب 10 لازم
اصدر اشياء كثيره لا تقييمه مضافه عاليه
عشان تعوض لي او تضيف الى اللي يسويه
البترول
هذا ما راح نحل الا بصناعه مبنيه
فهذه اهميه الصناعه عشان نجاح اقتصاد ان
شاء الله ونجاح رؤيه 20 30
الفتره اللي مرت خمس سنوات من اول 2018
اخر السنه هذه خمس سنوات العمل اللي صار
كبير جدا
زي ما ذكرتك في القطاع الاول الجميل في
اللقاء الاول الجميل في الرؤيا انا بيننا
توجههم رايحين
اهم برامج الرؤيه اطلقت في اول 2019
هذا اول ما صار في اول 2019
هيئه المحتوى المحلي لمساعده الحكوميه
والتغيير اللي صار الصندوق الصناعي
والمميزات الجبال
الصناعيه تغيرات كبيره كبيره
واخرها هذه
الوطنيه الصناعه التغيرات التي تم تم
كثيره جدا ومكنات كثيره
وذكر مع الوزير في لقاء الصندوق قبل اسبوع
ان الان
التحدي عندنا مو بس التغيير والتغيير الي
جاي اكثر ان شاء الله ولكن
اكثر منهم حتى عارف ايش المنتجات الاضافيه
والخدمات الاضافيه ومكونات اضافيه
الدوله
2019 36%
انما انما الصادرات تقريبا 30 40% انما
انما التوظيف من حوالي نفس النسبه وهذا
سنوات فيها سنوات الجائحه اللي يعني كل
شيء وقف وصار تحديات ومع ذلك وصلنا عنهم
عدد المصانع ب 25% فوجدنا نمو جميل
الصندوق الصندوق جميل
اليوم
عام 74
اتوقع انها سنه من عندي حتى الان انا اقول
لك وصلنا 2009
اللي صرفتوه في اربع سنوات من اطلاق
الرؤيا من
ابريل 2017 الى اليوم اعلى من مسار من عام
74 الى 2009 ونتوقع من نهايه السنه 2010
بس مو متاكد
فهذا كله في خمس سنوات
فيها اهميه الصناعه في التصدير في كده بعض
المختصين يقولون بان ما عمرنا حنفلح في
الصناعه طالما تركيزنا هو محتوى محلي
ومحتوى محلي وليس تصدير يعني مازلنا احنا
تركيزنا هو على كيف نصنع عشان نستهلك
محليا بس اعطني من كل هذه النجاحات سلعه
اليوم صرنا نصدرها سلعه معقده او سلعه
متقدمه وصلنا اليوم مصدرها غير النفط او
غير البترول المركز اللي هي من زمان
موجوده وعندنا فيها الميزان نفسيه
تتفق معها الكلام
ان اذا كان هدف نافاس التوطين ما رحت ما
راح يكفي لان المهم تطيع مفيد جدا
لدعم زلمه
هذا تقريبا 30%
اللي نجحنا فيه واللي كان جميل لنا السوق
السعودي السوق المفتوح
عاليه لا في
حد غريب ما كان في محتوى محلي شروط عاليه
ما كان في شيء ومع ذلك قدرنا نصدر
الصناعات غذائيه يقدر بعض الصناعات لان
بعض الصناعات اللي همم دائما
الصناعات الغذائيه زي ما مضخات صغيره
وتنتظر اللي عندي واللي راح مع الوزير انه
المحتوى المحلي مهم جدا لدعم الصادرات ابي
ابني قدره الانتاجيه بالمحتوى المحلي بس
يا بشرط عليه بكره بدعمك وبشتري منك عشان
تبدا
ابعد ادعمهم داخليا بس لازم لازم تصدر
فاحنا في المسار
2020 صادراتنا 369 من عندي 550 مليار في
وهل في قطاعات معينه نقول احنا عندنا قدره
النافسه اليوم في دول خلص يعني زي ما احنا
اليوم ما حد ينافسنا مثلا في تكلفه وهواء
مش ربح البترول لانه عندك قدرات
ارامكونتها على سنوات وعندك مزايا نسبيه
مرتبطه بالمكان بنفضيه حقتك صعب يجي حد
ينافسك خلاص انت بنيت ميزه هنا في قطاعات
ثانيه نفس الشيء العالم بنى سمعته وبنا
قدراته فيها فصعب انك تتنفس نفسه هل حددنا
قطاعات نقدر نركز عليها
وتتكلم على الفلسفه الي ذكرتها
في الصناعات الاساسيه والاساس في التكلفه
واللي عندك مثلا
يعني مصدر بترول تعديل شيء مواد اساسيه
مبنيه عليها وهذي مهمه وجيده نجحنا فيها
الصناعات المضافه هي مبنيه على الاستثمار
في الكادر البشري والتقنيه ما فيها حتى
اللي عنده قدره نفسيه من كان ينافس
التليفزيونات سوني صح احنا صغار
مره شفت التلفزيون الثاني
بوجود مستر معين والعماله رخيصه ولا كده
معتمده على الاستمرار في تطور
في التقنيه فساهل المنافسه فيها يعني ليش
كوري تقدر تنافس في همم الشيبس الكتروني
المعالجات ترى قبل 50 سنه ولا شيء ما عندي
شيء قبل 20 سنه
ليش امريكا
بتفتت نفسك
الدول بدات بالعماله الرخيصه عشان تربح
فلوس عشان تسافر والتقنيه عشان تنافس انا
الله رزقني
مو لازم ارجع اقول خلاص انا لازم
الوظائف الفلوس
اللي هي ابتعاث الشباب وشابات للعمل في
المصانه
ذا تقنيه الدوله بتحمل جزء من التكلفه انه
موظفينك بتوظفهم بعد سنه بيشتغلوا في
المصنع في كوريا ولا في المانيا ولا في
اليابان عشان يطورون قدرات الفنيه فاول
شيء لازم ناخذ
بداء القدره تنافسيه عشان نقدر عليه نركز
بالسياحه من يتخيل لانه بيصير عندي
مثال بنيت مطار حطيت مكان طورت المنطقه
هل عندي موضوع عشان البحر جميل البحر جميل
في العلا في البحر الاحمر
الجائحه في بعض القطاعات لازم امنيا امن
الصناعي عندكم موجوده
في المجموعه الثانيه تقول انا عندي سوق
هنا غير مدعوم غير مخلوق سوق المنطقه كلها
يا المنطقه العربيه ولا شرق افريقيا ولا
وسط اسيا ما في
ابي انا اكون مركز ثلاثه الامداد لها ولا
تشوف الان التغيير الي صار بعد الجائع
وبعد الحرب الاقتصاديه نشوفها بين امريكا
والصين شركات الكبرى تقول ما بيعتمد على
ثلاث امداد واحده ولا خط واحد
نقول حنا
تبي تخدم منطقه
في القمه السعوديه الصينيه اختيار الصين
جيزان منصه صناعيه الشركات الصينيه عشان
تختفي المنطقه كلها لان حتى هم بده يركز
كل مكان واحد لازم يكون فيه اعتماديه
وبركز الثالث قلنا نبي نكون قاعده في بعض
القطاعات الاساسيه هنا اللي هي يعني احنا
قاعدين نقول بجرب
عندي شباب
تعليميه وعندي فلوس احسن من كده
بعد القطاعات ان نبي نكون نحنا قاعده فيها
مثل سيارات كهربائيه ما في الحين ما في
الحين قاعده دوله قياديه في الصناعات
السيارات الكهربائيه حددنا في صناعه طيران
نبي نكون عندها قدره شرعيه كبيره
في بعض الصناعات العسكريه
والطيران وبعض وطبعا الكيميائيه ترى مهم
جدا
انا عندي همم يعني قدره كبيره عندي
عليها لاني عندي الغاز
سنغافوره ناجحه فيها ما عندها الغاز بس
الي اهم الغاز الي عندي 40 سنه كواد
البشريه وخبرات معرفيه عاليه جدا ليش ما
استفيد منها علاقات تسويقيه قدرات للبيع
موجوده جدا عاليه جدا نستخدم فيها وذكر
ضمير عبد العزيز
وزير الطاقه انه يعني 40 سنه بس الان خلاص
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل
[موسيقى]
ومن القطاع الصناعي لي لخصنا كده بشكل
سريع التحول الصافي الى الصندوق الصناعي
تحديدا
وايش اهم التحولات اللي صارت في
الخمسينات اللي فاتت ممكن نرجع نستخدم نفس
المناطق الثلاثه اللي استخدمتها في الحلقه
الاولى انت اللي هي على مستوى المنشئه
نفسها الصندوق القطاع الخاص وعلى مستوى
ثلاثه
الجهات حكوميه المنظومه
الاقرب
للقطاع الخاص هو المنتجات الماليه الجديده
في بناء المصنع
بعدين نوقف انا اعطيتك قرض مشاريع من
المشروع الدفاع عن الفلوس واستمر في عمله
ما عندي قدره اني اتعامل مع التحدياتها
ولا يستفيد من فراس
ماليه متعدده اطلقنا اخرها جدا
اسبوع الماضي في لقاء مع الوزير
اول شيء اطلق لنا شركه سنوق الصناعي
للاستثمار اللي بتعطينا القدره على اطلاق
باقي المنتجات منتجات التموينيه اطلقناها
اطلقنا راس مال العامل ثلاثه الامداد
الاستحوال متعدد الاغراض مجموعه صراحه غير
المشاريع
كان دقه بس للي عائله المخاطر اللي هي ما
هي المفروض اني اخذها بطريقه اقرب
الاستثمار لانه مخاطر رمزي استماره جريئه
وكده وما عندي قدره انا الصندوق نسويها مع
اطلاق الشركه صار عندي اداء النظاميه
نسويها هو اعلى الوزير انها تركز اعدام
شركات صغيره متوسطه واطلقنا اول شيء
برنامج الميسر يعني يصير همم
عن طريق الشركه وبدي التقديم فيها هذا اهم
شيء صار
بس لحظه بالضبط
هدفها هي اني عشان المنتجات الماليه اللي
بقدمها القرار خاصه
بعضها يحتاج تكون تحت النظام الشركات وليس
تحت النظام البنوك تنويه فلو تفكر في
البنوك التجاريه في البنك وفي الكابيتل
هذه اقرب لهذيك لو انا مثلا بعطي دعم
استثماري مثلا رواد الاعمال
منهم بس اذا جاك رائد اعمال عنده فكره
اسماء المخاطر اسماء الخاطر
حاولنا نجيبه الان مكنا كشركه اقدر ان
اقدم لها قطاع الصناعي
اعطيها مثلا
لو بعطي تمويل يتحول للملكيه ليش تحول
الملكيه اذا صار تحدي للرائد الاعمال رائد
الاعمال ما بيقول انت مديونني بعمرك الله
خذ اللي فيها مضافه عاليه وفيها تقنيه
احولها الملكيه في الشركه عشان اقدر ادعم
العمل يكبر ويتعامل مع التحديات انا ما
اقدر اسوي كده جهاز حكومي كشركه صار عندي
فالشركه تعطينا صلاحيه ومرونه في منتجات
ماليه
خارجتها الماليه حاليا اول منتج مالي اعلن
عنه يعني احنا
نتقدم عليه هي تمويل من السر اللي هي سير
تمويل في حال ضروري يتحول الى تركيا هذا
اعلن عنه مين المستفيدين منه او
المستهدفين ركزنا على رواده الاعمال همم
القيمه المضافه عاليه لازم يكون في تقنيه
جديده ولكن مضافه عليهم مصانع مرت بحضنات
المنظومه والشيعه
اهمها اللي في برنامج ندلب حق الفيل
وعندنا اتفاقيه مع دوله الملك سعود وعندنا
اتفاقيه مع مركز الامير سلطان ونعمل الان
وقعنا مع جامعه كاوسط بس ما اطلق لسه ومع
جامعات اخرى بس الثلاثه دول موجودين
همم الحاضنات هذه في القطاع الصناعي
مرشحين انهم ياخذوا منكم قرض قابل التحويل
الى الصناعيه
او طاقهم الجديده
اا صندوق العقاري ااا اسس شركه بس ما هي
ما هي نفس التوجه خدمه حاجات اخرى عندهم
اوكي همم هذا الاطار القطاع الخاص كان في
اتذكر انت تقول 25% من قيمه قروض همم
الصندوق في مناطق واحده يعدينا الان وصلنا
فوق ال 30% 30 %334%
طيب هنا في سؤال على سالفه انه مهم ان
نمكن المناطق الواعده
وهذه كفه تحترم مهمه وفي كفه ثانيه تقول
بس انت ما حتبني همم بني تحتيه متكامله او
ثلاثه الامداد متكامله اذا انت قاعد تشتت
نفسك في كل ناطق ليش ما يكون عندك حب او
ملصق رئيسيه هي اللي تنمو فيها المصانع شو
رايك
اذا باركز انا
بيقدر هو هو المستثمر بقدر قدره انتاجيه
وقدره التنفسيه مثلا سيارات بيجي الحين
جديد بروح رابط
يسير صار فيها لوس صار فيها كده صار فيه
تجمع هناك اذا انا باخدم مواد بنا في
المنطقه الشماليه
ما يغير يعني
بس الاقراب الحافز اللي مشكله ايش هو حفظ
الاشكال اذا كان يغير ربحيه اذا كان مصنع
خسران في الجوف وربحان في جده بس اعطيه
حافز عشان يروح الجوف لو انه خسران هنا
غيرت ما صار مستدام
حافز التموين لا تمويل ما يغير يخلي شيء
خسران
خليه يربح اكثر انا بقول لانك رحت الجوف
اتحداك والبنوك انا بعطيك تمويل اكثر يحسن
نفرق بين الحوافذ اللي تزيد الربحيه ولا
تزيد الجاذبيه من الحوافذ اللي يتغير من
شيء خسران
وفي اطاله القطاع الخاص كنتم تتكلمون على
موضوع مده ال ال الحصول على القرض في
مقابله بيقول لك انت تقول خفضلها من 11
الى 9 شهور وكان هدف اربع شهور اي ما
وصلنا وصلنا 24 ونص 24
من زمان يعني مو اول مره يصير اربع شهور
بعثتهم في ناس في في 20 يوم ياخذون في ناس
في ناس
المستثمر وعلى فعاليه جميلات
الهدف الجميل نحوشيه عمل مؤسسه اول شيء
حطيناه عن طريق المنصه ثم منصه تحسب وتقول
متى بدا بعدين قلنا مو كفايه عشان ما يضيع
المسؤوليه داخل الجهاز صار فيه زي
اتفاقيات حتى
انه اذا سلمت لك كذا ترى لك كم يوم ترد
واذا ما رديت عليها كذا وطلعتنا اغراض
يعني العمل طلع اذا سويتها كذا صار رده
فعل يصير الناس يقدمون في اخر لحظه
في تحسين مستمر الاتفاقيات الموجوده متى
يرفع للرئيس الشخصي يتاخر كيف نربطها
بمكافحه الاداء ما تصير فقط عقوبه وانما
ايضا تكريم فصار في عمل عليها حطينا مثلا
فريق يرجع لي مباشره حق التدخل السريع اذا
شاف صارت مشاكل يروح يتدخل عشان ما تصير
كاني
بين زملائي وبين زملاء في الصندوق وزملائي
قطاع خاص لا فريق ما يرجع لاحد يقيم هنا
وهنا واذا شاف في مشاكل شوفوا مسبب
الرئيسي للمشكله يحلها فنزلنا اوسيم 11
شهر كم معدل الى تسعه اشهر الى 17 الى
الحين اربع شهور ونص هنا مقيمنا من وقت
المويه للمشاريع لانها خاصه بمعظمها
مشاريع ترى اكثر من 85% مشاريع جديده
مبنيه على ورق مو زي البنك
عنده حسابك ويعرف كم تبيع باشوف ربحيتك
بعد اذنك على ورق ما في شيء فلازم نحنا
نتاكد انه في جدول
خمسه سته اشهر
خمسه اشهر
ثلاثه اشهر
في اغراض في تاخيرات في اوقات بعض الاشياء
اللي تشتغل من هنا ومن هنا ونعمل عليها بس
بالتاكيد الوضع افضل بكثير من السابق
وموضوع الضمانات يعني اشوف كثير الرسائل
اللي وصلتني على موضوع الى الان الصندوق
يشترط ويطلع ضمانات لو هي عندي ما اجيكم
بلغه كثير منهم اللي مثل الموضوع الارض
موضوع لكان تبدا تصرف وتخلص كل شيء قبل ما
تجينا طيب اذا صرفته خلاص
الا مثلا موضوع تحسين عوائل بس
فعليا قيمه الكبرى من القرضيه انك تبدا من
البدايه عشان تخفف عليه راس المال يحتاجه
خلينا نتكلم عن شيء نتكلم عن الضمانه
يتلخبط في الاسئله حلو في ضمانات اضافيه
تقويم القدره الماليه عند الشخص اللي يقول
انه عندي فلوس ما جئتكم وفي ثالث متى انا
ادفع
ممتاز احنا في السابع
وهنا المصنع ترى مو الحفظ حقوق الصندوق
العنب على ما احنا حبيبين مو زي البنوك مو
اذا كحيت بعلم المصنع فنتاخر ما بقى فيه
شيء بس عشان نحافظ على القدره الانتاجيه
في المملكه بس كنا في السابق تقريبا
تكلم عن ضمانات الاضافيه لكن نرهن رهونات
اضافيه كان تقريبا 40% من قروض الصندوق
رهنين شي حنا غير المصنع اراضي اشياء
ضمنات بنكيه اضافيه هذا نزلت اقل من 10%
معظمها حالات خاصه يكون الشخص عندهم
اشكاليه في سماء للاسف ما دفع احنا حديثين
نشوف اذا ما دفعت الصناديق ثانيه وعطلت
هلا
اذا ما كانت
احتمالي ايه بس خاصه مع الصناديق الحكوميه
يعني اذا ما كنت صاحب ثقه مع شيء ثاني ولا
مع نفسها السابق نطلب عليك اكثر من 40%
الى اكثر من 10% اليوم فقط
شيء ثاني يقول لو عندي فلوس حنا اول كنا
نتاكد انه هل عندك فلوس تقريبا ضعف
عشان نتاكد انك ترجع الفلوس
ولا لا مو عشان نرجع الفلوس
يعني 50 مليون ريال نصف السنه 10 مليار ما
راح تغير كثير في قدره الصندوق هي تحدي
على قدره انتاجيه والمستثمر نفسه لان انا
قررت حكومي ترى حضرتك 10 مليون وانت ما
عندك خلي المشروع 10 مليون انا بعطيك خمسه
مليون
ونصف
ولا كنت اقطع استراتيجي ولا منطقه واحده
انا بعطيك سبعه
ونص المفروض
بتاكد عندك بكلفك زياده مليون ونصف الى
خمسه مليون للتشغيل والتحديات وكده اذا
انت اوصل الربحيه انا بتاكد عندك فلوس
كافيه لما توصل ربحيه تفوز عندك مو كافيه
مصر
7 مليون
انا متاكد انك عندك مهم جدا
اذا
وقف
صار في اي تحدي صارت
صار تحدي بسيط في ثلاث ايام
ملزم بالقرض ولا عنده انتاج حكومي يعني
ترى قرض هذا قرض حكومي مو قرض قرار
ابراهيم ولا قرار هكذا
فاحنا نتاكد عنده قدرانيه تودينا شو نسوي
للشباب والشابات
الحمد لله الحين بعد خمس سنوات محاولات
طلعت الشركه ونقدر رايحين ان شاء الله
القيمه المضافه العاليه فقط
عندنا مشروع عادي قلنا يا اخي بساعدك جيب
مستمر
2019 تقريبا
دراسه جدوى مختومه مصدوق الصناعي قرضي
جاهز صار عندك قدره تفاونيه من المستثمرين
هذه بداناها
شفنا الاشياء اللي في قيمه مضافه اعلى ولا
مخاطره اعلى زي التقنيه لسه ما نجحت
والحين معي اطلاق الشركه ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
هذا محور المنشاه نفسها ايش اهم التحول
التحولات اللي صارت في فتره الماضيه صندوق
التغيير التغيير النظام النظام الجديد
اللي اعتمده رقم مجلس الوزراء 2019
سلمان وصل مليون ريال
اعتقدرت اهم مسجدنا لحد لا عشان فلوس
ولكن
شيء جديد عرفناه المشاريع العملاقه مو
الكبير العملاقه يعني فوق مليار ريال نطلب
عليهم اثر اقتصادي
متاكده مو بس الجدول اقتصاديه وانا مناثر
اقتصادي عالي الباقين سهل نشر
وما لقينا لاحد لاني اعترض ما عندي فلوس
التغيرات الثانيه الداخليه صراحه همم
الصندوق الجميل
صراحه ان استمرينا وبنينا على هذا التاريخ
الجميل
في شبابنا
برامج برنامج نخب في خيره شباب وشبات
برنامج الابتعاث انا عندي 25 شاب وشابه في
افضل عشر جامعات في العالم من سوريا
الصندوق عندنا فوق 110 اشخاص مبتعثين في
افضل 50 جامعه
وما تشرطون عليهم
الدوله
المشروع الوطني
قبولك انك تجيب ساعتين
ثلاثه
مهم نبي هل عدد السمر كان يعور قلبي من 20
سنه وانا ادرس انا اشوف دول لقد تكون اصغر
مننا ولا قدرات اقل مننا طالبات اكثر مننا
احنا مو ناقصه شيء الان الحمد لله زرت
الجامعات كل ما اروح اشوف الطلاب الطالبات
شوف في 50
في الثامن
التغيرات الثانيه صارت طريقه التحول لعمل
المؤسسه يعني الاتمتها والرقمناه وكتابه
الاجراءات عندنا هيك اجراءات بالكامل كتبت
ترقيات بين الادارات طريقه العمل فات
مؤثره بالكامل لا مع العميل ولا داخليا لا
يزال في اشياء يعني شو اسم النظام حقكم
تمكين في واحد يقول نص وقته رايح السيستم
داون واحد موظفينكم يقول يعني السيستم جيد
شكرا لهم بس صرنا مشغولين نصلح السيستم
اكثر مشهورين 2019
والنظام
كلها بغير شيء ترى نفسها ما تغير من
السبعينات نفس الكتابه تحسنت وبني عليها
بس هي نفس الاساسي
في السبعينات اللي كان مستعمل 2019
انا تغيرها بالكامل لازم
بدانا محاوله انها تغيير شوي شوي
ساره قرار
لا
من اطلاق النار
في اغراض كثيره بس ما راح يتحسن الى
المستخدم
بس لازم نغير يوم قلنا خلاص لازم كل
استخدمه
وتيره تحسين اهلا بكثير اعلى بكثير لان
اول
استخدمه في غلط ما في نظام تغييره تغير
كامل بدون اغلاط بس تقدر تقول
خلاص
العمل اللي صار والجهل الكبير بدل ميداتي
في الاجتماعات والمخاطر والتقنيه ظهور
اعمال في 2020
وتشكي وحقنه معه وهو صادق يعني بس هذا سعر
كنا لازم نحنا كلنا ندفعه علشان نصل وانا
منهم في موضوع الجاهزيه
الجاهزه الرقميه في فئه الحكومه الرقميه
اعلى مستوى الفجر
اكيد طبعا خنقسم بين نحنا الحين بعد نفس
الوقت حينغير نظام كامل كل سنه بنطلاع غير
ننطلق منتجات جديده فاحنا مو بس غير
النظام حتى المنتج اشتغل عليه يعني زمان
التقنيه الله يجزاهم عنك الخير كل ما نطلع
احنا والله تجنا برنامج تحفيظ جديد وانت
جديد طريقه تقييم الاجراءاتها كلها تحط
فيطلع عليها تحديات ومنتجات الجديده
المنتجات الاساسيه خلاص المشاكل ما هي
جوهريه
جوهريه في منتج شريحه بس
يعني حماس وشغف ما ما راح يصير شيء الا من
ضمن التغيرات اللي في المنشاه برده مساعد
موضوع التمثيل المراه اتذكر في مقابلتنا
كنت تكون انتقلنا من صفر
في المياه النساء في الموظفات في الصندوق
الى حدود 10% اخر احصائيه تابعته لكم
وصلتوا 22% الظاهر فواحد من زملائك يسالك
يقول ليش
يعني وش القيمه من اننا نفرض ونحدد نسبه
واحيانا يفرضون
يعني على حساب الكفاءه اذا كان في منافسه
تفضل المراه لان جزء من مشاهده
ما هي ما في مستهدف علينا الصندوق ان يزيد
نسبح بس انتم حاطين على انفسكم
»
ونتاكد من ايش مو مستهدف مستهدف يصير
مشكله اه انت عليك كيف تسوي كذا فصير
الطريق تتغير تعامره يتغير او تتغير عشان
نشوفها
مخرد يقول ليش ما وصلنا
الفرق
ماجد الشخصي السيدات في بدايه سقطبنا
شفنا المسبب ما بقول نجيبه نسبه سيدات طيب
كفاءه بس اقدر اقول انه لازم في كل منصب
قيادي على الاقل قابلت سيده احد مرشحات
سيده هذا في ترى يعني قد يكون بدون احساس
ويكون كده في ناس متعودين يمكن ما بدون ما
يحس يكون في انحياه ضد المراه والانحياز
بطريقه معينه ولو وجهه نظر معينه
كذا نبي نحارب الانحيازه ومعظمه ترى مو من
سوريا بس شيء طبيعي ان الواحد متعود على
اللي متعود عليه فكيف نحارب بدون نحط هدف
زي ما بيقول ابي حسين ب 155
وكذا والكفاءه في شخص ثاني يعني بس يقول
لي ما قدرت حتى تجيب مرشح لا هذا غير
مقبول ففرقنا بين المستهدف بدنا نشوف
النتيجه
جدا
يوم شفنا التنافس في بعض السنوات 50 100
هذه انفعت الشباب ما نفعت الشباب
اكثر ولا بس عندي جبات اكثر اكثر 20 20
وحده من سنتين كان عدد لو اخذنا على كفاءه
بس كان شبهه اعلى بس هن المخرج 50 50
ليش هذا الجهد يعني كيف كيف تفسر لها هذا
الجهد اللي همم لازاله العوائق او لفتح
الباب لها في قطاع ما هو معتاد يكون
مشاركه المراه في عاليه حتى عالميا صح
والله
يمكن همم
الدوله
المسافه الشباب
اكثر من شباب
عندك موضوع عنا كمستدفعت الرؤيه وتمكين
المراه والجانب الاخلاقي والاجتماعي
والديني فيها
اتكلم كا لو انا بس ابي مصلحه ابي افضل
الشباب
وعندي تحديات عندي 45 سنه اكيد مو عارفين
نتعامل معهم والا نتعامل وحتى هو امي
الدخول لو بقول هل معروض هذا يعني
مستثمر فيهم كيف استفيد منه عندي لو بس
بتكلم منه وجهه النظر فقط 2017
ساعه خلي بالكشكيه والطاقه همم
ولكن لما اشوف دفعت لكم الاقي انه مثلا
الصناعه اخذت 77 مليار مثلا بينما الطاقه
اخذت 200 مليون
من نقاركم همم
كنت اتكلم انت على انه يعني وقتها تخيلت
انه راح يكون في اكتساح لقطاع الطاقه كنت
تكون حتى المجمع السكني اللي بيحط الواح
شمسيه اذا سوى سجد واحنا نقرضه حتى هو
مجمع سكري ما شفتكم داخلين فيه ولا من
مشاريع الطاقه المتجدده لطرحت في السعوديه
مع
مصدرهم همم
تربيه القطاعات الاخرى اللي وظيفه الصندوق
هدف كل كانت حوالي برنامج الطاقه
النفطيهم كده وهنا نفسي اقوى المشاريع
الطاقه متجدده اللي بصراحه حكومي حكومه
قدامات
احنا نبي ندعم اللي بدون شرائحكم فكنا
نقول تعال انت راعي عندك مجمعات شعريه
تدعم جاريه واتفاق شراكه تجاري انا بموت»
التوسع ما صار هذا في المملكه كلها اليسار
اللي عن طريق الشراء الحكومي شرع الحكومي
ما نرى ان احنا المفروض ندعمنا نجوم اصلا
بشارع الحكومي
ونجح القطاع واستقطب استثمارات خارجيه
وقرض مملوك دوليه ليش انا ادخل واطلعها
احنا ما نرى ان المفروض نقدم عرضنا منتج
بسيط قلنا اذا بتزيد المحتوى المحليه
بعطيك 10% المشروع فقط
اا تاسيسيه بس
المشاريع اللوجستيه همم الخدمات الطرف
الثالث
الريال ترى في سنتين
ومنهارات قليله
اللي تدخل ضمن يعني استهدافكم او يعني
بسطه نقول اللي يسمعونا اليوم اذا عندكم
مشاريع في التعديل بالشكل معين او الطاقه
المتجدده الطاقه عموما ترى انتم مرحب فيكم
همم الطاقه المتجدده احنا مركزين عليها
اكثر يمكن بس حتى الطاقه الخدمات همم
الطاقه
اللي في المدن الصناعيه او الطاقه العاديه
في مدن الصناعيه او الطاقه المتجدده اللي
شراء تجاري بدون دعم دوله بدون ضمان
الدوله
اوكي فاذا كان طاقه متجدده شرعت تجاري او
طاقه عموما في مدن صناعيه الخدمه الصناعه
بدون شراء حكومي احنا المولى حلو الخدمات
الجنسيه ركزنا على اذا كانت داخل المدرسه
صناعيه اولها
الصندوق التحتيه او خدمات الطرف الثالث
تختم
قطاع الثانيه يعني مو مستخدم فقط شركتك
وانما تعرض الخدمات للشركات الثانيه او
حتى تستخدم شركتك بس ترفعت والرقمنا احنا
بس خدمات الطرف الثالث
[موسيقى]
الوزاره عندهم مبادره لها ما بعد
الاستكشاف في الحفر كده
20 30
10 مليار
معدل 13 15 سنه حلو في 20 30 لو انت قراته
15 مليار متخيل كيف تقسيمتها بتكون ذاك
الوقت بين القطاعات الاربعه هذه
لازاله اتوقع الغالب صناعي بين تعديني
ماجستي طاقه من جديد لان الطاقه
ما هو تحت نطاقنا والطاقه الكبيره اللي
غيرها بتكون تحتيه اوكي فاتوقع بيكون
الصناعه التعدين ان شاء الله التعدين ترى
تاخير لنا
يعتمد السنه هذه والرخص اطلقت السنه هذه
يعني
2019 2020 كان شفتها الحين عنده مرحله
استكشاف فيديو
الصندوق بس الحمد لله الرخصه جميله جدا
نتوقع ان شاء الله في السنه الجايه يبدا
تقديم على الصندوق نهايه السنه الجايه او
24 في واحده من مبادرات انا كنت مره مهتم
فيها ومتفائل فيها بس يبدون الامور ما هي
ماشيه كويس
مبادره تحويل 100 مصنع الى تقنيات الجيل
الرابع الصناعيه هذه بينكم بين المدن
لا في مبادره بيننا وبين المدن وصار العمل
فيها بس ما يحقق له شيء صح حقيقه المجموعه
لا الدراسه عنده الكبير منها اكثر التموين
احنا اللي اعطيناه ما استفاد منها العدد
الكافي صراحه
اول شيء كان غلطه من عندنا شروطنا كان
مركزين على اللازم يكون شركه ربحانه وكذا
وقالوا لنا الصناعيه طيب انا كمان
همم زائد الرقم وصلنا برامج تحفيزياء اللي
حطيناها كلها بين توطين وتنافسيه وكده
وصار ثلاثه مليون
التحدي الثاني كان كثير من دول تعطيه
ميزات اضافيه مو بس اغراض
الانف والتحدي ثاني كان انه شركاتك مو
عارفه مو عارفه ايش المطلوب مو بعرف شو
تسوي سوينا برامج مع اكاديميه
برامج تعريفيه مجانيه للموظفين سوينا
برنامج معرفيه عموم مع الشركات بس ما كان
كافي الحمد لله الاسبوع الماضي اطلاقنا
اتفاقيات مع 27 شركات هم يسوون الخدمه
انا بروح بعرف الناس عن المنتجات لان اي
شركه مستعد اتقدم خدمه الاتمته تعال
انا خلاص
حتى لا هو بعض الخدمات السريه بعضهم حتى
زيي في وقعنا مع شركات يعني زي
يعني زي كذا شركات تتقدم المنتجات نفسها
وكده فقلنا لهم سنايبر سنايبر وبعضها
وغيرهم الشركات السعوديه حتى بعد يقدمون
تنفيذ بعض يبعون الاجهزه فقلنا يا اخي انا
منسق انا وياك حلقه توم وجيري اذا نسيتها
الخط هذا بعطيك تمويل خلال ثمانيه اسابيع
رح
لات هذه وبعدين
خلاص
انا مثلا
قصه جميله في التحول لتقديات الجيل الرابع
واثرها على اداء المصنع هل متخيلين شيء
سويته ودعمتوا احد
كده في مصنع انتقل من الخساره الربحيه
المخزون وطريقه
جدا
بدل ما يشتغل فتره واحده او ثلاثه
تكلفه التشغيل
من الخساره الربحيه في مشروع تاني ارتفعت
المحيطه ب 8 او 9% لان بس اعمل عالجنا
موضوع التخزين حقه كيف انتقال من المنتج
من الانتاج التخزين للبيع
وقلنا حتى ما يكفي فقط اجهزه اطلق الخدمات
الشهريه واخرها
الانتاج قلنا تعال انا مختصين في الصندوق
يجونك صغيره جديد
[موسيقى]
وبدر التحفيظ يصير على المحليه هذه جميله
جدا هذه اللي يقول
شيء يمكن يعني تحديات كبيره يعني الحمدلله
عملنا عليها وانجزنا كثير منها وبقي كم
شيء الواحد يعني الحين انشاء الشركه
والمبادره هذه من اغلى ما تم اطلاقه صراحه
همم السنوات الماضيه
كتمكينا اللي الشركه للصندوق من بعض
اسماء العامل مهم جدا واستفاده منها
الشركات بسرعه وخاصه ومهم اثره كبير بس في
شيء اثرها بعيد النظام زي ذات راسمال وانا
عندي الشركه
هذه اثر بعيد هذا الشيء اللي بيبقى ان شاء
الله كثير هذه الوزير الصناعه بشغلها
الحين اول الصندوق الصناعي وزي ما ذكر
انا افتخر كانت بدره من فكره من سمو سيدي
ولا واحده الله يحفظها كان عندي فكره
معينه عليها
عادي الموبايل اقدر تعطيني قدره ماليه
نعطي منتجات ما كندرانيه
ليطلقت مثلا عشان اقول بمول هالشركات
الصغيره لازم اخفي المخاطره معينه لازم
اخذ كده النظام العادي النظام الدولي
والطريقه العاديه ما تسمح هذه المبادره
حطتنها ريحيه كبيره فمثلا دعم صغيره في
انشاء المصانع قدرنا بسببها
نعطي برامج تحفيزيه فالحين بصير اذا اخذت
سوف اتمنى
يعني بساعدك بيصير في دعم مباشر من الدوله
لك يعني مو بس بعطيك القرض بصير فيه دعم
غير القرض دعم مباشر من الدوله الدوله
بتعطيك انا سويت هذا مني انا هذا
الان مع المبادره
عندنا وبتشوف بتشوف ان شاء الله
طريقتها وحكمتها واليتها رائعه صراحه
بتشوف كل ربع ولكل ست شهور مبادره جديده
تحت المظله
اصدقاء ابو سعد
هذا يقول 35 تقدم واضح من ناحيه الشعر
القرارات
متاكد انكم تسولفون على المشهد الصناعي
لكن ودي اختار اهم قرار اثر على المنظومه
الصناعيه الفتره الماضيه
موضوع الصناعيه
الوزاره
موحده للمنظمه الصناعيه للتسهيل رحله
المسلسل
والعمل قصير على ربط الموافقات فمثلا
سويناها في الارض
موافق عندي مربوطه موافقه عند شوفها
ويشوفها هيتاخذ فتره اطول
منظور
المسافه
الزميل والزميله في مدنها
اكثر بس ربط الرحله من منظور المسافه
حتى يكون داخل الابتدائي
ما تدخل الى وحده مكان واحد هذا الحاصل
حاليا هذا كثير ما اكتمل وانما في الطريق
هذا بيحصل قليل هذا العمل عليه يعني
بطريقه جميله صراحه هذا يسال يقول ايش
اضافه الصندوق للصناعه من حيث خلق قطاع
جديده
بالسنوي لم اجد قطاع مختلفه عن الموجود
كلا القطاعات تقليديه
هل سؤال واضح لك
سؤال واضح هل هو صحيح انه ما ساهمته في
خلق قطعه جديده هي نفس القطعه
القديمه
سيارات كهربائيه بطاريه
الهيدروجين الاخضر هيدروجين الازرق كل
المشاريعنا كبيره كل سنه سنوات الماضيه
كده قطعه جديده
حاكيني عن وش بصير في تجمع السيارات
الصراحه يعني انك الواحد يعيش طفل العمر
تجارب وفترات يقوم مثلا التاريخ في سنوات
تمر بدون تاريخ وايام عقود عن ايام وايام
عن عقود صح نحن طبعا الحمد لله ست سنوات
نعيش كل يوم عناك مع الحركه القاسيه في
البلد
موضوع السيارات بالحاله انك هنا جزء من
خلق الصناعه
في المملكه صندوق من خلق المملكه
ترا يعني اتخيل بعد عشر سنوات 20 سنه يكون
عندنا ناس شباب وشابات شغلهم بسرعه سيارات
ومصدر جميل جدا
وفي مصنع سير واا شو اتفاقيه برضو واحده
من الشركات المحليه مع شركه الصينيه
البيضاء لتصنيع السيارات
طيب
اكثر ان شاء الله سيارات كهربائيه
شيء صح
الحنه
ثلاث سيارات فيها يعني موضوع دجاجه
والبيضه صح انه الشركات تقول ما اقدر انا
لازم يكون عندك
انا ما اقدر اسوي رجل الكفر واستورد الباب
وسوره يكلفني
واذا بجيب مصنع ابواب هناك
يجيب الفندق
البدائي مثلا
الان بنشوف الرهان الصناعي بدعي في
السيارات
انا كنت اتكلم كثير عشان ننجح في الصناعه
لازم رهان ما هو يعني
عندنا كده موجوده
اكيد بعضها بنت حلال ساهمت فيهم تقرضتم
كلهم
دور الدوله
منطقه الملك عبد الله الاقتصاديه فيها
الميناء الميناء جيد افضل المواقع في
العالم كبيره
همم
اللجنه الحوافذ البرنامج
بعد اثير قلت انا الحين جبت الصناعه اولى
الصناعات المتقدمه
فيها وهم يحتاجون الدعم وكذا
الثاني لازم اجيبه الشركات العالميه عشان
تبني لي الامداد ولازم ما اتاخر اقدر اجيب
سلاسل شركات كبيره وبس بس ما نجح اني اطور
سمعتي انا
البدايه
[موسيقى]
كده
نقول هذا علامه سعوديه
جميله جدا
جميله لنا ولهم
واللي نراه ان شاء الله شركات عالميه تبدا
تباعن انها تباعا انها تعلن انشاء مصانع
لها بالشراكه سعوديه في المملكه واذا صار
هذا الطلب كله موجود حيبقى يطلب ثلاثه
الامداد اللي هتبدا
في شركه
متقدمه
مفاوضاتهم كذلك طبعا
اذا المورد حط قيمه مضافه في المملكه
يقول همم الاستاذ الدكتور
والتعدي والظلم عن الموظف الصندوق القدامى
اللي ينظف فترات كبيره في الصندوق ولاهم
لكنهم الان يعيشوا مرحله تطفيش وتطنيش همم
فيقول اتمنى انك تنقل شكوى شكواي وشكوى
موظفين القدماء للدكتور ابراهيم شو رايك
عشان يعتذر منك اذا حساس الاحساس بس ما
راح صحيح انا عندي تحيز الصراحه تحيز لمين
تحيز اللي
يا اخي مبادره اللي يشتغل
ليل نهار بس اللي ياخذ المسؤوليه او يتحرك
كامل كامل
اول ما جيت كان مساعد مدير العام للائتمان
اصبح بعدين نائب الاهتمام نائب رئيس
الائتمان كان هو عمر الصندوق يعني في تحول
في عمل يجير تقريبا هو 40% من عدد
الموظفين
ومع سليمان
مشتركه
اساسا فتره التحول اللي ماسك خدمات العمل
الصندوق الداخلي الخدمه الخدمات مؤسسيه
55 سنه
خير فضل
خلصنا 2017
اليوم
قرروا انهم تقعدون وغلبوني بعد اربع سنوات
من الضمان من الصندوق هنا وهم اللي رشح
اصلا بدلاهم مافي
الجميل
يتغير بدون وجودكم ايمانكم وياما ترا
وجميل في الاثنين بصراحه يعني
غلط لا لكن بعضهم في الاستماع
بس اهم نغير النقاش حتى لو سؤال مو بيكون
في تحيه ولا لا السؤال هل هو العمل يصير
بطريقه مؤسسيه ولا لا هل هو يدار بشكل
شخصي ولا لا انا الهدف كان تكلمنا عن
ثلاثه اشياء بدنا نتحول الى عمل مؤسسي
الصندوق بني بطريقه جميله
مؤسسيه مع سنوات يعني بدها تغيير بس
الاساس موجود النجاح قائد
وتحرك وجاب رباب وناس
تكبر وتنزل
النجاح يكون هاي تقدر تحول عمل مؤسسه
اتكلم
الان تعيين القيادات في الصندوق رئيس فريق
مدير قسم انا ما ادري عنه مو بس ما
غير اذا بتقول بمكن صلاحيات صار مدير
الاداره هو اللي يعين رئيس الفريق مدير
الاداره يرشح مدير القسم ويوفق عليه
النائب الرئيس نائب رئيس سوريا عين مدير
القسم يرشح مدير الاداره وافق عليه الرئيس
التقييم كيف قلنا التقييم اول شيء جبنا
التقييم عام بدايه
الصندوق سويناها في 2018 سويناها 2020
عشان نقيم
النمو والاستثمار وكده فلاش خلاص
يختارهم يختار منهم 15 25 الان المجموعه
الثانيه بدات موجودين في لندن ارجعوا
الاسبوع الماضي ظاهر
يختارهم سواء برنامج
موجهين ويقيمون لازم يتاكد ان العمل مو
شخصيه
بدانا من ثلاث سنوات تقييم 360 لكل الناس
مو 360 اختياري واذا وحده من تقييمك
العادي
انت مدير فريق رئيس فريق 50% من التقييمك
ومنجازاتك هذه ما فيها تحيز معجبك رئيسك
يحبك ما يحبك ما فيها الارقام
يوقف وساعد في الترقيه في ناس تنزل تقييم
مهم تقريبا
او العكس فالان صار اختيار الاشخاص
وترقياتهم
اذا كان من قيادات اللي بيترقون يكون من
خريجين برنامج لقراءه الواعده اللي يغير
خارجيه ويدرس التقييم العادي تاثير
زملائكم موظفينك اعلى من تاثير رئيسك
وموجود التاريخ
ويتحسن مع الوقت ولا ينقص وهذا الرئيس
تنفيذي لها احد يعقوب
في لك انت احد يعني
[ضحك]
من
مجلس اداره السلام
العمل الخاص
فبدانا تطبيق العمل على نفس الشيء عندنا
لازم تعاقب قيمه الناس
يعني الحمد لله لان العمل موجود عمل
بطريقه مؤسسيه ترى هذا التقويم الي صار
هذا المرشحين بغض النظر ابراهيم مش اولاد
لا لازم اختار من الان مرشحين واعتمدوا
اللجنه التشريحات
اوكي
يعني فقدت الطموح في المنظمه لان مالي
مرشح
لمنصور رئيس التنفي
كل الناس مرشحين
مع فتره ثمرت في نفسك بس المرحله هذه افضل
ثلاث يعني مو انت غير مرشح افضل ثلاث
يعني حتى اخترنا وخلاص وحطينا الترتيب
وقلت لها الاولويه في الان ولا الان
واردهنا المجلس
الاختيار اثنين اللي همم
هل تزعل وانت عارف انه مسببات اسنان قش
احسن ما تصير كاني اضحك عليك وتضحك علي لا
بالعكس الحمد لله انتقال بيكون شرس جدا
اطلاقنا منصب نائب رئيس اعلى هذا الكلام
من ثلاثه اربعه اشهر بدا الانتقاد بكون
سرس جدا مثل اخر يوم عمل لك لان هذه
الحلقه بتنشر في 27 او 25 ديسمبر تقريبا
ان شاء الله اخر يوم واحد واحد باذن
الرحمن
اللي بعدها مستمر ما ودك ترتبط امم اثرك
يعني ما ودي اكون افكر فيك مكانه لان يجوز
للمقطع الحكومي اكثر من افكر في الاثر
الاتركه مقارنه بما سبق بعد خمس سنوات
افكاري والجهد الموجود في ان شاء الله من
من يضيف افضل واحسن والجميله الان نشوفها
ان الاثر اللي تقدر في البلد صار من جهتين
التغيرات الاساسيه في القضاء الحكومي صارت
تحسين الانظمه تحسين الممكنات كثير منها
اثار
الان في مجال كبير
فان شاء الله ان يكون جزء من القصه هذه
الفتره الجايه بعد الصندوق همم اسس همم
والقاضي
همم متحمسين
افكار قدرات ودي اكون جزء مقسمه نجاح هذه
وفقت اني كنت نجاح عن طريق الصندوق
مسؤول حكومي ان شاء الله انه يكون جزء من
قصص نجاحهم هذه ان شاء الله عن طريق اياك
مستثمر ولا كشريك
باذن الرحمن
2017 الى اخر 2019 ينفصلت الوزاره وعملت
مع ابو ابراهيم من 2019
سحب كثير يعني كان مرشد و استاذ من ايام
ارامكو من اسئله
وجابني للعمل الحكومي ومكني فيه كثير
فمدين لها بيفضل كبير بعد الله سبحانه
وتعالى حتى نتقابل ابوي قبل قال لها ترى
للحكومه لكن تقول له يرجع ولا شيء ولا
اخذنا همم في المدينه بكثير همم اسلوب همم
يعني هو يمكن يركز على
ما هي السوره الكبيره ايش نسوي طموح دائما
عالي جدا وكيف نغير وسنضرب بعد عشر سنوات
وكل ما نطمح يعطيك طموح اكبر مركز على
مثلا المشاريع النوعيه اكثر على قد دوليه
والشغل هذه كانت كثير
تعبت منك كثير تعلمت منها كيف اكون طموح
كبير كيف ما شاء الله هو ما يوقف ليل نهار
اكثر واحد شفته سيدي من وقته حتى يضحك معه
قال بعد بعد ما طلع من الوزاره وكذا قال
شلون العمل
الصندوق مستمر بس ابو عبد العزيز
موسم الريال
ضحك يعني ما شاء الله
اقدر اتكلم واعطي قرارات واخذ توجه
مع ان صلاحيه مع معانيه ولا مع كذا وانا
عارف ان دائما يعني دائما بانيها على وجهه
نظر وعندي سبب
امشوا وانا ماشي همم بصراحه التمكين اللي
صارت الماضيه عالي جدا من ابراهيم حرصه
على القطاع الخاص جاء اسمعهم تحدياتهم
تجربتها ايضا هو اقرا خاص فهذه تعلمت منها
كثير كيف الناظر
احنا نعلم منتجات
مانع هالحين كمنتج انا انجزتها
خاص تغير وجهه نظر هذه المنظور المستثمر
الشخص اللي في المصنع تعلم منك كثير
حريص على روح الفريق فاحنا كمنظومه دائما
مع بعض دائما سوينا مثلا رحله للعلا اطلب
منك شغلنا فان دافور
مسؤوليتكم
الصندوق سوينا برنامج
ارسال المنظومه
خلال سنه وشوي رحنا للعلى بشره عمل يومين
سوينا برامج تدريبيه طبعا زدت الدراسه
وجبنا برامج ايضا
جميل جدا
وشكرا على العمل
[موسيقى]